[Music]
there was a brawl involving two thousand
workers at one of the Chinese factories
where they make products for Apple two
thousand workers got into a brawl
apparently the pressure to make all
these new iPhone 5s has gotten to the
workers and it finally resulted in a
riot but not to worry Apple as always as
being very proactive in dealing with the
situation take a look at Apple we take
the well-being of Chinese workers who
assemble our products very seriously
when there's a problem we solve it the
only way we know how we innovate
introducing the Apple I ship the
thinnest lightest factory riot weapon
yet it completely changes the way
assembly line workers protect themselves
during a violent factory riot
we've made the blade 18% rustier and the
new handle is contoured to fit perfectly
in an adolescent workers hand it's also
28% thinner so it can be hidden anywhere
inside the body and we need anywhere the
new Apple I ship there's already a six
month waiting list
[Applause]
you
[Music]